des stores serré que celui de pierre
goldman universitaire brillant écrivain
de talent il était allé jusqu'au bout de
se révolte on avait beaucoup parlé de
lui il ya cinq ans il était alors accusé
du meurtre de deux pharmaciennes à paris
le 16 décembre 1969 deux pharmaciennes
du boulevard richard lenoir sont
assassinés en s'enfuyant le tueur baisse
grièvement un policier
quinze jours plus tard à la suite d'une
dénonciation pierre goldman alors âgé de
25 ans est arrêté tous l'accusent la
description des témoins le fait qu'il se
soit trouvé dans le quartier au moment
de l'assassinât
goldman nie ce double meurtre est le
niera toujours mais en 1974 il est
condamné à la prison à vie en avril 76
le verdict est cassée par la cour d'amis
certains témoins se récuse d'épreuves
s'efface goldman est acquitté des deux
meurtres du boulevard richard lenoir
mais condamné à 12 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour trois agressions qu'il
reconnaît il bénéficie d'une remise de
peine et en novembre 76 il sort de
prison
ces années de prison n'ont pas changé le
caractère et l'idéologie de coleman
marqué par ses origines juives marginal
révolté il écrit en cellule deux thèses
l'une sur jean paul sartre l'autre sur
l'amérique latine qu'il connaît bien
pour s'être battus en 66 aux côtés des
maquisards avant de choisir les
barricades de mai 68
écrivain de talent il publie un ouvrage
remarqué intitulé souvenirs obscurs d'un
juif polonais né en france puis devient
journaliste à libération et ne fait plus
parler de lui jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec
une mort tragique de celles dont sont
souvent victimes des aventuriers à
l'itinéraire tourmenté comme pierre
goldman le groupe bonheur de la police
qui revendique le meurtre de pierre
goldman s'était déjà manifestée au mois
de mai dernier en revendiquant le
plasticage de la voiture de militants
cgt
il affirmait alors vouloir venger un
gardien de la paix blessées pendant les
manifestations du 23 mars
mais tout le monde n'est pas